there are many deities and spirits
throughout Greek mythology that have
some kind of tie or association to death
and the underworld in today's video we
take a look at a group of female spirits
that were often tired to violent and
cruel death including murder ravaging
disease and death in battle these
spirits were loved one of the many
children of NYX and they will refer to
as the karez or the gears as it's
pronounced in Greek they would often be
seen as the opposite to their brother
Thanatos a spirit or God that we more
commonly associate with non violent
death and it was fairly common for the
gears to be regarded as the agents of
the mirror or the morai the goddesses of
fate who would measure the length of
someone's life when they entered the
world when that time had come to an end
they would notify the Gita's who would
make sure that that individuals life
would come to an end when expected
because of their violent nature and they
were often associated with the Morrow's
or the morose a group of female spirits
they would often drive men insane and
towards their inevitable destruction
unlike Thanatos who's thought to merely
bring death the gears were seen as
craving blood feasting upon the bodies
of those they killed before sending them
to the underworld they were thought to
be so numerous that thousands would
haunt the battlefields in the same way
that vultures and other carrion birds
would fight amongst each other over the
dying and they were believed to have no
direct power over who died or when they
died but their hunger for blood off the
men that they would ignore these
boundaries even killing those who fate
had dictated and what ready to die it's
believed that only the gods had the
power to stop the killers and they will
amongst the favourites of Zeus who would
often send them to bring death to
particular individuals quicker than fate
had planned the physical appearance does
vary were some thought to be nothing
more than the personification of disease
and plague other times they were
depicted as famed and Talend women
dressed in bloody garments that somewhat
resembled the ironies of bloodthirsty
harpies there are some that believed
when Pandora's jar was opened the evil
spirits released upon mankind or in fact
aqueles Hesiod himself refers to the
personified version of the Kira's the
nossos the bringers of plague sickness
and disease in later mentions of Greek
mythology it's thought that the gillis
could be in
by incantations and they were described
as the hounds of Hades pouncing upon
living men feeding on their souls
throughout Greek mythology there is a
recurrent theme of vengeful spirits and
goddesses and the Gators do give us an
interesting variation they somewhat
resemble the arenas in that they are
both ancient beings that once did the
biddings of the gods but the Gilders arm
also associated of death and the urine
ooze were thought to bring justice and
punishment as always I'd like to know
what you guys think do you think they
appeared as ventral women of an appetite
for blood that could not be satisfied or
perhaps you think they represented
rampant disease that's thread of that
care for the lives that it claimed let
me know in the comments below